[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm link and I'm
Rhett this week at the round table of
dim lighting we are asking the question
what happened in Thailand and the UK and
we should know because we were there yes
and this is last two weeks vacation and
as is normal we haven't talked to each
other in any great detail about what we
did because we wanted to save it for
this and I would say these are as
extensive as any vacations we've ever
been on and as a result we got to talk
about both of them we're actually gonna
do this over the course of two episodes
let's make it a six-part over the next
six weeks and I want to be very linked
slowly and painfully unravel their
vacation we probably could do that but
we're not we're not gonna do that
and no and we're doing it as two parts
not because we're trying to milk as much
as we can but how can I put this
something happened on my vacation the
Scotland part with my mom that deserves
I don't want to I don't know exactly
what happened but I don't want to I
don't want to short I don't want a short
circuit or cut short the yeah yeah that
tail it deserves its own place its own
story and just and it was bad what
happened wasn't good
no it wasn't it wasn't you seem like
you're but well I'm not means as a
teaser okay and that's it and this is
for not this episode sorry this is for
the doing stuff this is for the next
episode so I don't know how far we're
gonna get with your vacation my vacation
and I don't want to the second episode
to just be about what happened to my mom
because I'm sure there'll be stuff that
you still want to talk about stuff that
I want to talk about yeah I'm just
saying that we're saving that story for
the second one and we're gonna just kind
of cover what happened and we're just
kind of pop lore well and we'll Bop back
and forth and I got notes like all the
stuff that happened on our vacations we
I have notes every every once in a while
but this is I'm gonna be like
referencing my note
because there's weren't you there yeah
yeah but so many things happen like okay
well let me just quickly I'll just
summarize what what I did okay moving
your notes out so it seems like you're
not know so you're off book no this is
my side of the table okay I could put up
a barrier I'm just trying to help you
don't reach across to my side of the
table I'm just trying to hit like that
was on my side of the tables my business
and you know what it stays on yeah well
you just reached across and grab my
notes we're here so we can't see each
other I mean it's it's a podcast we
don't need to see each other um there
are some podcasts where they're like in
different places in the nation or the
world those are really awkward so and
this isn't I as you know I took my
family my family being my immediate
family my wife and kids but also my
brother his wife their four kids and my
parents this is a long awaited and
planned trip to the homeland of Scotland
and the whole idea was to spend a week
in Scotland with them which we did going
to three different places in Scotland
and then we dropped them at the airport
after a week and then just the the
California McLaughlin's continued on
down through the UK stopping into
England stopping in York and then the
Cotswolds a day in Oxford it's so funny
that all of the places that you're
naming are so different sounding than
all the places that I went yeah oh yeah
we had definitely opposite vacation yeah
yeah I guess I could have been in like
Greenland or Antarctica or something but
and then and then London which of course
we've been to and then you spent a
weekend and I've got some I got some
developed thoughts about London now oh
yeah so I I want to compare notes
literally comparing notes with you
because you spent a week there but you
went to so many places yet to look at
you had to look at your notes to
remember even the next well six
different lodging lodgings in two weeks
which is uh which is a lot yeah I'm
excited
about it you as a McLaughlin you went
back to the to the McLaughlin epicenter
with all the McLaughlin's that was the
idea then the idea was that was supposed
to be special so I guess the big
question that oh it was no it's very
special but was it in a particular way
over this in the next episode of course
you know I'm Ty Neil is a is a tie last
name right so I've always wanted to go
back and get in touch with with my oh
there you go there's your motivation my
family no I just took my immediate
family and smart smart my wife three
children and that's it it's a lot
cheaper when you do that what if you owe
me let me I say let me just say bet more
money more quickly than I've ever spent
Wow I mean it was just like if it was
like one of those cartoons where I saw
like a cash register just one that's I
kept just seeing that in my periphery
man yeah I am I guess I split some money
is that what this is about
hey man I spent money through this thing
I've been saying like I've been thinking
about it a lot and you know me I don't
think about much yeah yeah when you
spend that much that's a long as you
have to start thinking about it we took
the 14 hour plane ride to into Hong Kong
and then immediately connected to
Bangkok that was not the original plan
I'll get into that in a little bit
stayed in Bangkok for a number of days
and then we flew to chiang rai which is
the northern mountainous territory right
on the border of Thailand with Laos and
Myanmar in the Golden Triangle we stayed
there for another handful of days
elephants jungle well I want mountains
jump out what I'll call a jungle but it
wasn't a jungle
what was it it was treason it was just
very
lush lush lush vegetation jungle to me
it was but probably technically it was
not what I was very now what does a
jungle technically I don't know because
they didn't go too long I don't think
mmm and then I flew down to Koh Samui Co
means Island so Moy is the name of that
island ko some way so some more so then
so we wrapped up our trip with just the
quintessential beachfront hammock on the
beach coconut in hand corncob another
hand if you follow me on instagram bot
so that's how I wrapped it up seven
seven flights yeah total to get around
all those places once you factor in
connections with a who's counting oh my
wife is definitely counting because she
has a flight phobia and I'm not trying
to make light of it I'm just trying to
do an Oprah impression but oh man she
was a champ
she took it like a champ it wasn't easy
hmm when you're coming into that island
boy we took a little drop out of the sky
love a shoe pop it's like a little
interesting interesting thing about your
family having someone who is as a flight
phobia
you've had a lot more flight issues than
anyone that I know like if you go back
through like the stories of being like
on a tarmac forever or experiencing
really crazy turbulence yeah like I mean
the reason she has like I just have my
fear I just haven't had that I probably
would be scared if I'd had a bad
experience but I haven't ever had
anything that I you know I don't think
about you know yeah it is my fault and
you know what she loves me enough to
endure it well that wasn't what I was
suggesting but you're that's what you're
internalizing so no I'm just owning it
okay it's the truth you're not you're
not somehow it's my phone out the pilot
or the airline or whoever's fought it is
if I don't want to be in legal trouble
here shut up
so yeah we we skipped all around we did
lots of things I I got it I got notes
here but I don't want anybody to see him
so I'm gonna keep him off camera I just
wanted to seem like I remember what
happened well you'll know when I'm
referencing my notes it's just so I can
know when to say what not when to say
but what to remember one thing I didn't
do is shave if you would like to
acknowledge my beard I don't know if
you're oh I well I don't know if you're
threatened I'm already threatened you I
mean I've already seen it and do I look
like I would be threatened by a small
beard at this point yeah your beard too
getting a large man right yes that's
that's an in depth conversation for
another time
basically at a certain point I'm a
vacation I'm not gonna shave and if I
skip two days with with travel water and
what it does to my face it's like makes
the hairs harder or something what it's
even it gets it's harder for me to just
hack through my beard and some I'm
hacking it one day I'm like you know
rival water it's a different consistency
I know about that yeah what hard or soft
it's a little different than my home
water but definitely yeah and it yeah I
know about that makes my hair but it
does not but but sometimes getting
theoretically sometimes it would make it
easier to shave it made it harder to
shave I'm saying in practice so this
particular travel water my razor got
clogged up so you just say tie water I
didn't have a backup I didn't want to
put it on tie no no I'm just saying that
some water saw some was hard you know it
when you go on vacation and you start
lathering up and you're like the lathers
different yep yeah well travel water I
know what you mean but unless I just
wanted I really just wanted to know how
much gray is on my face now well quite a
bit yeah yeah I'm getting yeah yeah yeah
we're in the salt is beating the pepper
at this point cetera is it really though
yes the light but the salt is too I
think it's our 85th yeah well I mean
maybe overall but definitely like in the
most forward-facing part the the right
right here
salt is 75% and I remember when I first
started to get facial hair this is the
place where the places widest now is the
place where I first started to get
facial hair and that makes sense that's
not what happened with me because I'm
getting white right here and I didn't
start growing back corners of your chin
jaw line right here and then a little
bit in the middle right under your which
I will say that this is probably I mean
well the mustache is the thing that came
in first for most dudes
so my mustache I've got no gray the
blackest part in this series did not
yeah not true doesn't work and it's
blacker right you know that in the
corners of my mouth we'll discuss next
I've got like a horseshoe mustache with
like an old man growing around it we'll
discuss this in detail later but how
much older do I that twelve years the
terminal length of your hair changes
based on how far it is from the center
of your face so the terminal length of
hair right in the middle of your face is
the shortest I've been watching lots of
videos about beards well your hair looks
the longest in the middle of your videos
like right here so the terminal length
of your hair right there's this whole
patch I have not cut or trimmed the soul
patch in 36 months and that's the that's
the terminal link that's as long as it's
gonna get you washed it all the time
okay good and I'm gonna wash anything
also right in your butt crack but if
you're gonna watch two things it should
be a buck crack and then that's so
packed but it moves it basically changes
over the course of your face I don't
know if that I don't think that applies
to the hair on your head but you haven't
researched that cuz I don't have like
really short hair right in the middle I
guess what technically maybe like a like
a widow's peak is a little short yeah
anyway I learned that watching YouTube
videos about beers we're devoting two
episodes to our vacation and we're going
in depth about our facial hair because
that's what we care most about I can't
keep this thing much longer it's itching
the crap out of me you get pet you'll
get past that but you only thing you
have a white beard and I mean I know
they could be cool I just I I just
really wanted to know
now I do yeah how much shave this stuff
I think when we're done with this
podcast I'm gonna I'm gonna shave it off
Oh how's the water here that's my kind
of joke that's my kind of joke that's a
very bad joke yeah it's not really yeah
it's just it's not really a joke no but
it kind of is it's too quick it was
pretty good it's equipped it's not not a
sponsor yeah speaking of which
occasionally a sponsor yeah let's get
into sponsors man just to get that over
with okay
it's clip a sponsor because that would
be really cool right now well today the
sponsor is us these these these mugs ear
biscuits mugs available at mythical calm
for 10% off tempers and up if you want
your face to look older get a mug hold
it next to it if you want your face to
you look younger drink from it it's that
magical and that's not my drink from it
I like younger see yeah
and then when I move it away well yours
older 50 52 53 53 53 I'm 41 now I
honestly I think that you just you look
closer to your age I'd be charitable and
say that I think most people would look
at you with that beard and be like oh
he's prematurely gray I don't think they
would be like oh he's old you look at
Anderson Cooper you don't think he's 72
you know what I'm saying premature has a
negative connotation in every instance
that I can think of it being used
prematurely smart yeah
never heard that prematurely graduated
I've never heard that yeah I've heard of
a premature early bloomer premature baby
ivory mature I'm just saying that I
don't think you look 53 omission I don't
think it adds 12 years to your your real
age I think it'd get you closer to your
actually I like the fact that you're
backtracking a little bit but you're
doing it within
the ad that's only in the video version
right well I'd like I like to make I
like to reward the people who watch the
video for the video version red actually
thinks that I look my age but for the
audio only version 12 years older 12
years older go to mythical dot-com we
don't have to say mythical dot store
anymore it's all one thing it's all one
thing mr. go TOCOM get all types of
stuff beard oil we both need that now
hey I could use the beard oil before I
right before you shave yeah I wouldn't
advise that oh okay all right so let's
get into this man you you want to start
where did you where did you what did you
land Edinboro Edinboro that's how you
say it
well that's how I say it okay tell me
which interestingly is what Jesse he
raised an interesting question while we
were traveling through the throughout
the UK Scotland and England United
Kingdom everyone in our group me
included had this tendency to when we
were not around locals as we were
talking amongst ourselves we would go
into our best accents of the region
right obviously that started as a
Scottish thing and then by the time we
were just with our family in England it
went we were like trying to change the
way that we talked and Jesse and I'm not
gonna attempt to do it because it's not
good I don't have it won't sit you it
will sound stupid now that I'm willing
to do stupid things but do it it's okay
if you do I I you've got to have some
words that you go to bards is that the
word that you go to whether it helps
work what what happens is you'll be in a
conversation with a local person and
then they'll walk away and then they'll
start talking you'll immediately start
talking like them because you just had
this interaction with them and Jesse was
like do people do this when they come to
America and we just don't know it well
are Americans the worst at this thing
going to up now first of all I will also
say that for good read
there are certain places that if you
were to do that it would just be
immediately labeled as a racist right
like what I did if I did it right every
time somebody no I did not do that dude
I'm not about to do it because I would
it be it would be right but I'm right
right and I don't want to explore the
whys what that what that is necessarily
but it seems pretty obvious that me as a
McGlothlin going back to you know
quote-unquote my people I can go back
and I can try to sound like them
whatever there are still some groups you
can make fun of I think Scottish and
English people are still still two of
them so but jesse was like but but
someone from Thailand someone with the
Thai accent I would like to hear them do
a Scottish accent
well that's that's an interesting point
that's not what I'm talking about it
wrong for me to say I'm talking about
the phenomenon of Americans talking in
the British or Scottish accent the the
English or Scottish accent when they're
in those places and then do people from
Scotland in England when they come to
America start talking like hey guys you
know when like our friend Jaden from
Australia does yeah he does his American
accent and he always goes into this
character which has got to be how right
we perceive they perceive us we go into
the character you're not you don't seem
like a Scottish person you seem like a
character conjurer like there would be
in like some play you know you know it
was just an interesting question because
I think that we're probably the worst at
doing that maybe not though I mean I
know for a fact that many people that I
interact with like acquaintances are
less not friends in Los Angeles I will
be having a conversation people come
into the office who we don't know it'll
be for a meeting and I know for a fact
that over the course of the conversation
they will start to adopt a southern
accent and it and some people will go
farther than others and it happens with
southern accent so it will see
like an impression and I and what this
happens with you yes this happens with
our wives a lot more than it happens
with us I but I notice that people are
doing it and it's and I think do they
think that I've been doing some that
I've been doing an accident for comedic
effect at times and then they start
doing it for comedic it's just a natural
i I feel like this isn't a slightly
different but again these are mostly
Americans and I'm interactive it and and
I feel like that's I feel like that's
affecting your accent a little bit to be
even more relatable which I understand
that and have probably done that but
this is more like arguing with each
other about who does the best Scottish
accent you know like twelve Americans
going around doing horrible Scottish
accents and trying to say who's doing a
better one like that is I believe that's
an American phenomenon I don't think
that twelve Scottish people come to
America sit around maybe they do let me
know if I'm wrong but you're assuming
the worst let's hope for the best yeah
so we started in n bura and then we and
we you know we had limit the way that I
kept characterizing the entire vacation
was this is a sampler platter of
everywhere of Scotland and then of
England because any particular place
that we were at we could have stayed for
much longer and I think that the thing
that kind of wore on me and even though
I tried to prepare myself for this was I
felt responsible for the for the
enjoyment of the entire group right this
was my idea is your idea this is my idea
I'm paying for it and I will say big big
thanks to Jenna for being very involved
in the planning of this in fact there
was sort of a there was a runner a
runner that people people would do
something like we'd have a good meal and
then my dad would be like thanks Jenna
right you didn't invite her to come you
just right and and she was also
instrumental in planning your vacation
too so a lot of the specific choices
about well this is where we're going to
be was based on her research and her
kind of planning that out are you
setting her up to blame her for whatever
the crap happened to your mom no no
because that in particular was all my
idea
like whole thing Oh where'd that happen
okay good
no but I'm saying that great actually
even though I had someone to help us
make the decisions about what we were
going to do I still felt like my song
was all on me and so I tried to be
honest on Jen if it goes bad I try to be
very strategic about okay you got 12
people ranging in age from 10 like 75
you it's tough what you did man and and
I and I told Jessi going and I was like
I am already just committing to not
enjoying this I mean I know that sounds
like a very pessimistic thing but like I
have a tendency to get really excited
about vacations and I always think that
are gonna be great and then they can be
a little bit hard or disappointing
inside this was like listen I'm not
doing this for my personal enjoyment I'm
doing it for the enjoyment of the group
which I actually think that even that
was unhealthy I should have gone in with
very little attachment to outcome mm-hmm
but let me just say apart from that
thing that happened to my mom which I'll
talk about it was an incredible vacation
it was it was great but there was this
constant pressure of well you got to go
to so many places this this sense of
FOMO in every place that we went and
then this like okay I've got to start
planning like okay I have to tell the
group that we need to be out the door at
8:30 because we really need to be out
the door at 9:00 you know like I had to
start kind of adjusting to the way that
the group was going to but you carry
around a pole with like a flag on the
end and like had them o'clock and we sit
and we didn't all wear the same like
neon t-shirts it wasn't a family reunion
how did everybody stay together well I
don't even know I don't we didn't even
do a buddy system ID it just nobody got
lost as far as I know so like give me
give me a rundown a day one if you're
like rattling through this thing well
like what's the first thing you did okay
well so the first thing I did
we met in JFK like they flew from North
Carolina we I'm not really interested in
the airports well well you're gonna
understand this is this is relevant I'm
not just trying to start from the
beginning I made the decision to get
first-class tickets for the adults in
the group now there's six adults in this
group first-class international tickets
are expensive but I decided to do this
because I was like we're gonna fly
overnight on Friday night and I want my
parents especially gets be able to sleep
because getting a good night's rest
helps so much with that adjustment -
yeah the time change they didn't sleep
at all
my mom may have slept for like 30
minutes even though we had these like
lay down seats it was like she just
couldn't get comfortable so right out
right out the gate I felt a little bit
like a failure I was like it also was
like I saw that cash register I was like
oh that was for nothing
yeah you know did you go over and like
layer seat down tuck her in nope that's
the flight that's the flight attendants
job or at least my dad's but yeah so
they didn't really sleep a lot of oil
and and so we get there cuz my idea was
like you sleep and then you get there
and then we're gonna like immediately
bagpipes go do I play bagpipes find the
nearest bagpipe start squeezing on it
right begin experiencing the city which
we kind of had to do because you
couldn't get to your room until like
three o'clock which I think we ended up
getting into one room at like 1:00 p.m.
anyway so the first day personally it's
just raining just like just torrential
raining at times
what does it rain there is it like is it
water like whisk travel water what did I
drink I don't know but I did see
something that said today's rain is
tomorrow's whiskey I saw that a lot of
different places
well you had tomorrow's with me it was a
rain but so I was like and then I looked
at the forecast and booked for both
England Scotland and England like if you
just look at like your quick weather app
on the phone it was rain whisky whisky
every single
every single day and I was like okay
you're on a downward spiral emotionally
it sounds like well it and I immediately
was just kind of overcome with this we
got to see everything now I want to I'm
gonna talk pretty extensively about the
driving because that was a thing but I'm
let me throw it back over to you because
what that was kind of my mindset going
in was this just this weight of
responsibility I just need to know do
bagpipes happen at any point just yes or
no ice yeah okay good I could not have
done what you did with planning for that
many people I mean yeah you know I mean
based on my report from London when it
was just me Christie and Lilly like I
was a wreck on the train platform I
don't want to rehash that but like I
mean I thought about just like having a
lottery about who's gonna go with me on
this trip just to keep it so I could
have a good time just logistically I
loved my entire family equally you know
we're planning this thing we were gonna
go to Hong Kong for a few days Bangkok
for a few days in in chiang rai and Koh
Samui but then Chrissy and I made the
collective decision to simplify and
spend more time in less places so we cut
out Bangkok and we were just gonna stay
in Hong Kong because you have to fly in
a Hong Kong anyway hmm
but then you know there's so much
political unrest in Hong Kong there had
for weeks there have been protests and
since it's gotten even more dire you've
seen it in the news sit-ins at the
airport protests all throughout the city
with Hong Kongers basically these other
corector yes yeah okay
that's what's what's all over Twitter I
just thought you made it up no yeah and
really yeah Hong Kongers how about Hong
Kong geun's
yeah stay out of it
I mean I just feel like that help I
should help okay well then staying in a
Scottish accent Hong Kong geders
at work I think it was two days it might
have been 24 hours before we're leaving
I don't know exactly but it was it was
we were we were packing finalized in our
packing and we make the decision there's
people getting beat up protestors are
getting beat up on this on on the
streets of Hong Kong yeah Congress a few
days before this so we we made a
decision to not stay in Hong Kong at all
I'd done all this research for Hong Kong
oh and it's all of this real an amazing
city all right you were excited I know
coz just I was like Jesse's favorite
place that she went and when she was
over there and then we decided last
minute we we cancelled all of that and
just booked a hotel in Bangkok and
started finding things to do in Bangkok
like as we were packing to go to not
Hong Kong anymore turns out we didn't
have to pack anything different though
so I didn't have to change that it was
just but right off the bat like I'm
discombobulated big time right I'm in a
totally different city than I'm gonna be
in but we get to Bangkok and we were
told from friends who had been there
that Bangkok is really overwhelming and
there's a river that runs through the
middle of it and our hotel was on the
river and we were told you can do a lot
of river taxis as opposed to just doing
Street taxis because the transportation
is the streets are just really crazy so
the more you can just travel on the
river the better I'm like well that
sounds fun anyway
so we get there and it's late at night
so we check into the hotel and we go to
sleep we get up the next morning we're
like all right let's do some exploring
day one we're just gonna kind of we're
gonna get on this river taxi we're gonna
go up the river or down the river I
don't know which way we're gonna get off
over here where the concierge told us
that we could walk around we're just
gonna start walking around mm-hmm it was
so hot there I mean it was I mean we had
just spent a few days in North Carolina
the week before like filming some stuff
and it was it was it was more torturous
than that in terms of the humidity I
mean it was you
was just yeah did you wear a tank top
yeah I was like I wish I had a tank top
you should ask me I would have told you
to pay back some I don't know one as a
policy there's a time for a tank top and
I think Thailand is the place I could
have gotten one there because let me
tell you they sell everything everywhere
in Bangkok we're walking around that
like the the main one of the main
attractions which is the Golden Palace
was closed because it was the King's
birthday there's pictures of the King
everywhere everybody loves the king they
loved him Urdu they have to love him it
seems like they legitimately love this
camera it's effective propaganda when
his dad died we had a tour guide for
another thing that I'm going to tell you
about we got kind of the lowdown on how
they felt about the King and at least
from her perspective she was like the
king and the queen are like members of
our family we have pictures of them in
the house everyone does and it's not
something that's required that before
it's not something that's required this
is her talking it's just how we feel
about him and when when the previous
king died for like there was like months
of mourning keeping the king from like
being a teenager until he was like
almost 90 so like everybody live their
entire lives just knowing this guy's
their King and he's like on Billboard's
everywhere how long is the new king been
the King a couple of years oh it was his
birthday as I said but I'm when the when
the previous King died like all of the
programming on television changed to be
sadder or commemorative and everything
was changed to be in black and white for
over a month all all television shows
they just like put the black and white
filter on it if you die do you want me
to continue on with GMM and black and
white for a month because I'll do it six
weeks I do not think they worshipped the
King like I didn't spend too much time
digging into this but okay well there
ninety-four percent of the population is
Buddhist okay right so that's where they
were that's where their allegiance
okay right right but the king is in the
mix let me tell you because his picture
of course the Buddha is is lounging
everywhere - yeah everywhere you go
Buddha is kicking it I mean there's
Buddha sitting covered in bronze big
ones little ones laying down ones I mean
Buddha Buddha will recline oh yeah
he will relax he will and he doesn't
have a lot of core strength why is gonna
be critical of no I'm not being critical
I'm just saying like he's not worried
about that you talk about that belly
yeah I like it it's very relaxing to sit
like that you ever sit like that just
let it all hang man I gotta look at my
notes oh we all talk about course tree
now you know I've told you this story
about last time my dad came into Los
Angeles we were driving down the street
I was taking him back to the airport and
we passed a Thai restaurant and it the
sign said Thai food right and he said
out loud
food and so you may be wondering if you
knew that story if that's the whole
reason I went to Thailand and I've come
to grips with the fact that I think the
answer is subconsciously absolutely yes
because my dad said five food I was like
I gotta go get me some of that five food
right so we're walking around it's
blistering hot what the palace is closed
one of the main things to see it's like
it's a mile just to walk past the
outside of the palace what do you have
on I have on breathable shorts I got
some walkable shoes okay so no nice toe
box not Oprah open-toed you know what no
one's doing open-toed um yeah I think
Lilly is some sandals on all right
t-shirt and other things which I'll get
into later okay but um people are on the
street the streets are like Target the
streets are like Walmart they're selling
stuff everywhere Street markets there's
a flower market it's like the second
largest flower market in the world to
Holland and they're like you go in there
it's amazing how much stuff
they're making floral arrangements that
then are you can take to the temples as
like what's the word this is offering an
offering there's people there's Thai
land is famous for street food you know
they're they're like grilling stuff
everywhere anything you can smell and
imagine smelling you smell anything you
can imagine hearing you're talking
honking screaming grunting scraping you
hear it all at once you smell it all at
once and you feel it you feel you feel
everything you feel the heat well--don't
scrapes you sweat coming out of places
that I didn't know I were places on me
right and we walked for a long did you
get some food just like random hey
listen we picked up some stuff like oh
there's a there's a stand it just put
two pomegranates and you can just got to
get pomegranate juice for like 20 cents
now is there any concern about 29 baht
to a dollar so it's like oh it's nothing
going up and I mean there's a lot of
places you can't just go drink the juice
of the pomegranate you'll end up with
crazy diarrhea but that's not the case
here did you did you look into that or I
got it I got to get back to that too but
I'm gonna say I'm just saying no not
exactly
that didn't happen okay
but you had you just act on we drink
bottled water but you can't do that in
Mexico for instance like you should I
didn't really check on it I just wanted
some pomegranate juice drugged
all right good it's it's so hot like
everybody start I think there's gonna
somebody's gonna have a heatstroke we're
just not used to this right like my
family is wilting and I'm like oh my
gosh I gotta find some AC and they do
there's malls everywhere too but I was
in a I was in a place where there wasn't
one of these they have these like huge
indoor air conditioned malls that
everybody goes to so I tried to find one
on Google and we went to this mall and
it turned out to be
pretty small but it was like so three
stories and it kind of felt like a
market kind of thing but it was in the
same thing as outside but inside so not
the type of mall that I would picture
just saying the word mall but they had a
food court on the top floor we're up
there and I'm just trying to get an iced
coffee and trying to get trying to keep
people hydrated because they support it
right and I'm wondering if I might get
recognized in this land and lo and
behold about that time this guy comes up
to me and it's like it turns out he was
a local and he was like are you from
here he had a good he spoke really good
English he didn't having that much of an
accident he was it like more of a
traveled guy but he was from there
originally so I don't know if he grew up
in Thailand but he lived there now and
was from there and I was like yeah I'm
I'm him and he's like can I can I get a
photo and we're like he was super nice
and he was like what are you doing here
like yeah people tend to ask that what
Dad went past I was like no dude I've
just every everyone who's been to
Thailand has told me it's amazing I've
got to come and so I'm here and with my
family and it's our first full day and
he was like no why are you here in this
food court yeah I understand why you're
in Bangkok
a major travel destination food wasn't
bad in the food court we we recovered
and then we we hit the streets again and
wrap things up so I can give you more
but what's the next thing that happened
on your trip one of the things I was a
little bit worried about was the driving
as you may be aware you drive on the
left side of the road do you okay so I'm
worried about this and it's not just
that I have to drive on the left side of
the road it's that I'm driving a large
van a nine passenger which that is key
for later van okay so it was like this
one of those big white vans well it was
black it was this it was like one of
those Mercedes vans that
there's three rows of three seats
including the front seat is three rows I
mean it's three seats like there's a
seat in the middle we didn't reuse it
but so it's a big van driving on the
left side of the road and it's already
raining and I'm also getting out at the
airport so I'm not like on some country
road it's like you're immediately in it
you thrust and then in course I'm
driving one van and my brother's driving
in the other van he's done this before
he's driven on the left side of the road
in somewhere in the Caribbean I don't
know
Oh in the Caribbean but he was also like
he said it wasn't fun and I was kind of
freaked out you kind of time I would
imagine you're constantly you know
second-guessing if you're if you're on
the view in the right place if you're
going the right direction well let me
get to that so and then I notice as we
go we go out to the woman at the at the
rental-car desk
my brother and I do and she's like
there's a there's a big container of
wristbands and the wristbands say stay
on the left
hey look like the same kind of like
rubber wristbands that we sell oh I say
mythical on them you can get so she was
like take one of those that's something
like okay that's foreboding so I put one
on my left hand and didn't want to
really confuse myself and and then my
brother is like well no then they're
like would you like the additional
insurance this is always a this is this
a frustrating question hate that
question because you're like well I
don't I don't know I don't think I don't
think I need it you know I think because
I've my own insurance buy insurance and
then I met at a credit card card has
sort of court is supposed to have
something something on the fine print of
that yeah so I think I'm okay I think
I'm okay because it's generative figure
and also because of the time change I
mean like all the people that I need my
lifeline Jenna is sleepy yeah at this
point because this this is like the
morning right so so I'm just like I
I'm just gonna go for it because I've
got the credit card in my insurance and
of course the greatest insurance policy
is me as a driver put that on the
wristband and I put that okay so you it
you put on the wristband
I'm surprised yeah put that is shame no
it's not that's like I mean why not put
like a stamp on your forehead that says
dumb tourist well it's a wristband so
it's a little more subtle than that
but then with it we get to the car and I
will say there was a Mercedes and there
was a Hyundai
and I felt bad about this but I took the
Mercedes because I was like I'm paying
for both the Mercedes and the Hyundai at
least I'm gonna do is get the Mercedes
okay but also I had to continue on with
my family for another week I was like
okay our sadie's van is kinda like a
there's no difference ultimately I mean
mine's a little nicer it's really no
difference so this my seat the seats
have much time
and it's the we get into the the vans
and then there's another there's a large
sticker on the windshield this is
sitting on the left I'm like this must
be a thing this must be an important
thing to remember this must be something
that people don't always remember if
they've you know something had to happen
before the wristbands in the sticker you
drive with your lizard brain a lot you
know and also in that picture in that
thing on the windshield it says stay on
the left is a picture of a roundabout
and like how to enter in navigate around
oh god some light okay roundabout was
there blood on the picture it was
there's like there's blood all over the
so I am oh and then my brother asks the
the woman who's showing us to the car
she like he sees the wristbands and the
stickers and everything he's like so I
mean when was the last time an American
had an accident with you guys and she
and her face was like do you really want
me to answer that and she said this
morning yeah so this happens and then
I'm thinking she should have said it's
about two
game and then I'm really thinking like
the insurance thing I'm like I don't
know if I'm covered don't see you said
no I can enter into financial ruin
yeah it's like a Mercedes van here is
how much this thing cost hit a Scotsman
he was he's gonna sue you I get in the
car I started up and first of all task 1
is just to back the car into a different
space so that everyone can load their
luggage into the car underneath this
awning please tell me you backed up and
all you heard was a bunch of bagpipes
run over oh yeah
but it's felt so foreign it really it
really did I couldn't even back up no no
it's like man there's a whole lot of car
over there and I used to so much car
over there and there's no car over here
yeah I'm saying like this is like wow
yeah it's a lot to think about that I
haven't thought about over there I've
never thought about over there now
there's where most of there is you know
yeah like that's the first thing that
we're I'm thinking about there's nothing
to throw some up in there
but I keep thinking about that there's
something where there wasn't something
and there's nothing where there was
something that was the biggest thing and
so you're like I have to account for the
footage over here so I don't run into
things up with the left side of the car
because I'm on the right side I get it
you know I get it now yeah with the
brain I understand on paper so but we
get I back in and get everything packed
into the car and then I'm like okay call
here you know this is the address this
is where we're going the address of the
hotel I'm sure we're gonna go separate
it we can't be trying to beat it
together that's smart
like we can't worry about that that's
the only smart thing you've said because
someone's going to make a mistake so
forget this whole staying together thing
put the put the address in and hit
someone I don't want to see it is what
that was code for and mistake number one
was I just pull out of the rental car
parking lot and real and then I see two
large trucks coming at what in two lanes
and I'm like I'm going the wrong I
wasn't on the wrong side of the road it
was I I wasn't I was still in the
airport so I
not like out on the highway okay I had
gone out an entrance only thing because
I didn't understand that the they don't
have first of all they have so many men
on this side no they have so many signs
you explain but the sign didn't say no
exit it just was a symbol that I didn't
understand and it looked like I could go
you know what that symbol means Amy oh I
know no it means don't go that don't
know it don't enter but you know what in
America yeah wrong way which I that
computes to me wrong way okay I won't go
that way so but I immediately I again
what they weren't like but they were
going like five miles per hour because
we were all still in like the parking
area kind of situation I was able to
split up to turn around so then I go out
the correct way and within 100 yards
come to my first roundabout and again I
haven't read it but I I didn't do any
research I had all these plans of like
I'm gonna watch a youtube video about
adjusting to this I'm gonna like go on
my son's like Forza isn't the name of it
yeah game game where I'm gonna drive on
the left side of the road of course I
didn't do any of that so I'm just facing
it in the rain trying to fit where's all
the windshield wipers they're on this
side of course they are and so I I pull
out I see the roundabouts I don't know
when I don't know what exactly what I'm
supposed to do here but I can kind of
see from my directions and I supposed to
go around it and then head off in this
direction I get into the roundabout and
I'm like I think that I'm looking at the
navigation and then I'm looking at the
roundabout I'm like I did I kind of get
disoriented and I just take one of the
spires off of them is about it use crap
she's the one that I thought was the
right one it was the wrong one and I'm
like I'm already screwing up they just
went into just a hotel parking lot well
that's good so which also had another
roundabout first of all in a parking lot
the roundabouts are everywhere and let
me just say that after two weeks of
doing this well I would say I had
somebody tell me three days you'll
adjust I would say it happened earlier
than that there were no more close calls
even the rest of that
Trip of driving into n bura going
through multiple roundabouts by the time
I got to the hotel I was like this isn't
going to be that difficult
it wasn't until we went to the highlands
so after being in an burro for a couple
of days and I basically just drove to
the hotel left the car park to the hotel
and then took public transportation all
around the city so it wasn't like I was
traveling all around the city the real
driving started when we had to drive
across the country up to Glencoe which
is basically the gateway to the Highland
so like the Scottish Highlands that
you've seen in postcards and that kind
of thing okay there's a little town
called Glencoe that is right inside the
highlands but not like you could go for
hours and hours and hours to go up to
like Loch Ness and all that which we
didn't end up doing but that trip of
driving up there driving across the
country then driving into the highlands
that was when things got very real
because not only here on the left side
of the road which I kind of gotten used
to the roads are like comically narrow
like unbelievably narrow like wow why
are they so narrow you're asking
yourself the entire time they got a lot
of space right there's no shoulder at
all on most of the roads so you know
like first of all our roads are a little
bit wider than the car yeah
the especially when I was in a van it
felt like it was just as wide as my van
and if there's no shoulder if we don't
have a shoulder there's a sign that says
no shoulder that's how far we go they
just let you know when there is a
shoulder that's what's I say it's the
other way around but you're driving
through the highlands and then there's
like a you know like a 700 year old rock
wall on the side of the road that's
right up next to the thing right up next
to the shoulder there's no shoulder and
then there's another rock wall on the
other side oh and then there's these
semi trucks or let you do that got a
drive they got a drive up there to the
Highland somehow they're a little bit
narrower than what we would have in
America but they're still massive giant
trucks with large trailers behind them
and that those guys are basic
I don't know how they do it they're
fitting in this very small spot and then
the tourist buses hmm this is buses and
buses of tourists who are coming up same
width and then what was happening
initially as I would like move over a
little bit just instinctively to not hit
them and I would hit the little I would
go off the road like my left wheel would
go off the road and then I'd be able to
get back on I think Paul and I were like
constantly like checking in with each
other and we both kind of independently
discovered you kind of have to lean into
the oncoming traffic you know saying you
just overcome your your tennis you don't
want to pull away and just lean in a
little bit like I am my mirror you might
touch Knight you steer into him are you
just yeah yeah your head lean you're
sort of mentally leaning but you're also
turning a little bit so you're like
hugging that like grinding your teeth
and your pucker in your anus oh yeah
very very tight the whole time but I'd
say by the end I was actually having fun
but the one the biggest difference that
is racing death there was absolutely no
way that I was going to fall asleep
while driving because you had to be so
on top of everything was work everything
yeah and tight you were so engaged
whereas here you're just like listen
wrote the road is you know 40 feet wide
there's extra lanes there's a shoulder
this is wide as the road itself you just
basically just go to sleep you're not no
one's gonna fall asleep at the wheel
there because you're so engaged but I
but I oh and while I'm up in Glencoe
I'll move on from driving and throw it
back to you but while I'm up in Glencoe
which by the way one of the most
beautiful thing places I've ever seen
very much reminded me of Kauai place
that you've also been in terms of just
these incredibly green giant faces of
mountains that don't like there's some
that have trees is some that have note
and there's not a tree on it it's just
great it's it's one of the most
beautiful landscapes I've ever been in
and driving through that well trying to
like navigate
look and enjoy the scenery but also not
run into the tourist bus that was a
little harrowing but while I'm up there
in this little town I basically find out
through Jenna that no I'm not I'm not
covered I don't owe my insurance does
not cover this and oh my credit card the
fine print on the credit card says has
all the exclusions and one of them is 9
plus passenger vans and I have a nine
passenger van so I'm up there and I'm
like I got no place to go I get to
physically go into one of the locations
so I'm like I gotta make it into one of
these locations here without wrecking
your tea tree but thankfully Jenna was
able to talk to people to handle our
insurance stuff and they were able to
get it and it basically give us a
temporary policy until I could get to
the next location so that I would be
covered by insurance so that put me at
ease a little bit and in addition I was
able to stop in one of the places and
pay that pay the fee but anyway I didn't
wreck just went off the road a few times
you know in the wrong direction quite a
few times and here's one hot tip going
back to the roundabout you know when in
doubt on a roundabout keep round and
about cuz all you gonna do is circle
around right don't exit just because
well let me tell you circle I am Pro
roundabout now in fact when in doubt
keep rounding about I'm all about the
roundabouts now I think that it's a
superior way to navigate than a traffic
light yeah okay whatever on our second
full day in Thailand I had I'd signed us
up for a day trip out to Ayodhya
which is the the original capital city
of Thailand so it's built in the I think
this was well I know because I'm looking
at this now mid 14th century
so thirteen thirteen fifty you're
building all of these watts which is the
word for temple out there and if you
watched Mortal Kombat the movie 1995
the opening scene fight scene is there
oh really
and man I gotta tell you I love me some
ruins man you would have loved it here
too
did you go to Stonehenge I told you to
go to Stonehenge I could tell by the
look on your face you did it I'm not
going I didn't go I have good reasons
all right I I respect you you had a lot
to do
I have a stone phobia wood man got stone
phobia so they've got this entire city
that was it it was it was taken over and
it was it was ransacked but it wasn't
completely destroyed and so a lot of
these and you can look on my Instagram
for one of my only two post was a selfie
I took there that was a lot of fun to go
there
like I said 94% of the population is
Buddhist it's actually a requirement for
all men but by 822 serve as a monk for
like six six weeks no longer than that
three months hmm but it's voluntary and
some people do it for much less maybe
even just a day or two but that just
goes to show you about it's required but
voluntary you gotta you have to do it
for some length of time I think from a
practical standpoint they're not there
it's expected okay is is how it ends up
shaking out you know yeah and there are
there's so many temples you know there's
like tens of thousands of temples all
over Thailand and these ruins are ruins
of some of those original temples that
then around Bangkok you see like the
modern form which is basically the same
so it's very fancy and ornate right
you can't miss these temples literally
they're everywhere but also some of the
most famous things to see in Bangkok not
in iitai oh where where we saw the
ruined older versions of the temples is
to see these temples so what we didn't
go to any of the temples it's the thing
to do but we didn't do it yeah we kept
saying we're gonna go visit this temple
like we went on the
and we would see the temples from I mean
from like a block away or something and
they're absolutely amazingly ornate and
I really wanted to see him but we just
think it was so much to do when you
factor in shopping and like
air-conditioned malls after day one and
how I like burnt my family and wilted
them we ended up not walking around too
many temples alright well it's
interesting because we you know there's
the equivalent are the the giant old
ornate churches of Scotland in England
that we we actually ended up going in
quite a few cathedrals yeah so you know
there's this there's like st. Giles
Cathedral and and bura of course we did
Westminster Abbey and in in London which
I think you had seen as well and there
is a point there is a point where you're
like kind of like okay this is
absolutely incredible the level of
craftsmanship in this place is detail
bonkers but ice once you've seen
Westminster Abbey it's like okay I'm
gonna go into another one it's gonna be
basically they took the same approach
I'm not saying that it by the end of the
trip I was like I don't need to see any
more of these because I feel like I've
seen it but the interesting thing in
this it sounds like you you experienced
the same thing there's a whole lot of
this sensation of going into a place and
being like this place was built in the
year 1050
in the 11th century or the 10th century
or whatever yeah and then you kind of
just be like man this place is old and
you kind of just sit in the old Miss
there's like a lot that's fun it is but
I didn't till it's not anymore
well no but we would just do it
everywhere it's like this is the oldest
bar and all of the UK and you go in
there and you're like man this place is
old yeah nod your head a little bit like
man so it being at such an old place I
knew that's how the kids would feel
that's why we did I mean I enjoy their
little joy I'm just saying that like
it's a phenomenon to just go to an old
thing and just talk about how old it is
but the the room
more fun because you could walk on they
let you walk on it a lot of it you can
just walk on and walk up and stuff and
there was one that we can still go
inside
and again there's not much in there but
it's like and then they've got all these
old Buddha statues that are like falling
apart and you can see this that like the
skeleton is made out of wood and it's
exposed and then it used to be bronze
very ornate so I really loved I you taya
that was that was totally worth the date
trip there and then you know getting
carsick on the way back trying to figure
out why my ATM card wouldn't work for
three hours did you straighten that out
straightened it out yeah but I mean we
took a canal to it there's lots of
canals off of the main river in Bangkok
and that was a lot of fun being able to
see a lot of the houses and a lot of the
temples that are off the main drag and
these monitor lizards swimming in the
canals that are like six feet long and
like their trunk is like bigger around
in my trunk just swimming they're not
safe right they they have venom but they
if they were to they might hurt an
infant or like a little tot of a toddler
but they're in the park they're the
elite turtles and dead fish and stuff
like that but it was cool to see him I
thought it was a freakin alligator and
then it started climbing up the stairs
into somebody's backyard it was a
freaking monitor lizard I call it a
komodo dragon but that's telling Komodo
dragons are they're dangerous for real
though it wasn't a komodo dragon but
then that night that second night it hit
me it hasn't hit me
digestive Li you know I'm saying yeah
I'm not having any movement you know you
talk about getting the pomegranate juice
or like eating the street meat or how
many days this is this is um the second
that well the third night right okay I'm
like I'm not gone that's what profit
this is like summer camp all over again
and I'm
I gotta do something about this you
didn't take your fiber with you didn't
take my fiber with me because I've been
I've been drinking my breakfast smoothie
religiously with this some flaxseed in
it and I don't take fiber anymore and I
took my breakfast smoothie pack but I
didn't take my flaxseed that's a big
mistake man and you know with with my
anxiety I think everyone grows in white
yeah everything puckers up you got to
worry about that fiber everything pokers
up like you drivin on the on the
cobblestone street so wherever you were
mm-hmm so then I'm going down to like
the drugstore and I'm like man I gotta
get I gotta get this you win so you you
went straight to enema like I Chris
Christie had a bunch of these stool
softener pills there's a nice day
there's a few steps before enema I'm
just saying a few steps for enemas for
like 36 hours before that I had started
taking stool softener pills like two
three at a time
nothing and I could just feel that like
there was like oh gosh I was just I was
getting bottom heavy not good man and I
you know so we're we're at the end we're
in the middle of the street we're like
trying to find a pharmacy and like
nothing's in English in the pharmacy and
it's like and they're not gonna draw a
picture of an enema so it's like you had
to demonstrate don't leak you took like
a Barbie doll in there I'm like this is
what I yeah I brought I did bring a
Barbie doll for it so that I could
communicate with people well okay what's
great what did this American going up
with a bit of a Barbie doll like doing
that motion it's like what am I asking
for that's true you are in Bangkok yeah
we can't be careful so I brought you
back a souvenir that's very special to
me hold on it's not the turn is it
look at that this is what I found
give him a little ASMR there now open it
it did have some English on it it's a
little little packet open it yeah it's
it's it's for you souvenir it's the
thing that meant the most of me on my
trip I've got that hold that up for the
people it's a lollipop now this is an
infant or baby enema which is the only
thing I could find
this one doesn't would you double or
triple up on this what yeah it had the
other ones that I bought had a at a ball
hated babies picture on it so I was like
well I guess I need to get three so I
got three and I squeezed two up in their
first night and I sat down and they had
this there was a trash can in front of
the hold on you what about the toilet
back in the hotel room i sat down I got
confused I said and oh my gosh nothing I
was just pain yeah you should have gone
to maybe three or four I went to pain
man and I grabbed the head this a little
Trash Can I grab that and I like I tried
to create a squatty potty situation like
and then Chris he's like walking in like
I need to wash my face before I go to
bed I'm like that's not a good time I
mean he's like you look like you're
about to rock it into space how many
times did you reference chip
oh don't use his last hey a friend from
college who shower mean last nameless
okay [ __ ] be okay he went to he spent
like months in China and then he ate too
much rice and didn't go and like deliver
legendary story oh man I mean he had
like a 12-hour bout with like a he had a
baby someone actually adopted his turn
after it was that bad he took it to the
local to the local adoption I was so
scared that that was gonna happen to me
like it was a painful night and then
like the next day nothing so then the
next day so too
later I'm in the same situation again
I'm gonna quit holding this by the way
that was not used it was in a sealed
package it still got the top sealed on
it but by the time we got to our second
destination we left Bangkok so you did
nothing came out no it did work but then
two days later I'm doing the same thing
again it's just like my my lower reading
elapsed right
rice noodles rice and noodles here you
got a yeah you had a balance I doubt
meats but I'm not a lot of fiber in any
of that not a lot of fiber but um I
became it's like it shut down like my
intestines just shut down
they froze so the these bulbs became
very special to me and I had to go buy
more I had to go buy more and you have
to be buy you have to be careful how we
can't just be become reliant on enemas
well let me tell you about that the
moment I got home I went up to my toilet
totally good totally fine it was like it
it's like my body new it's like my butt
new when it hit my seat
everything was fine you know what
lucinda i've switched to the fiber there
the gummy fibers fiber gummies yeah
because you're you're regressing I'm you
I'm using infant bulbs and you're using
it I just don't taste good I just took
three a day no problems man because I
was my diet was like a lot a lot of meat
a lot of like pot meat pies and bringing
like a meta me like a fiber mix is they
think as a problem and it looks like
drugs you know TSA makes you makes you
open it up tell them what it is so that
I mean that was the highlight of my
Bangkok trip was was these little bulbs
you know I'll talk about Chiang Rai and
then Costa Moy when you talk about your
mom I'm not saying you're done with
anything else you want to say here but
I'll save all that stuff for the next
one but I'm just to summarize Bangkok
for me as overwhelming as it was in
every way I think it was it was very
memorable too like I felt like we really
experienced the city like walking around
like we did we did sign up for a food
tour where a guy walks us around and
like gets us to eat food from places on
the street that like we probably
wouldn't have had the guts to eat on our
own like we we ate this papaya salad
that you know he helped them make it not
too spicy because that you know they
could really torch an American over
there and then we're eating this like
pork and rice thing and everyone was
like oh this is really good and then we
walk around the corner to where he got
it from because he just brought it
around the corner to us and it was just
a bunch of pigs feet hanging out it was
a pigs feet and rice place and I'm glad
we ate it first
because you've had pigs feed though I
know but I don't elect to have it but it
was great and then he's like he kept
taking us on shortcuts and he would say
I'm gonna take you on a shortcut through
this next Street Market and it would be
this back alley where it would just be
dark and rats running everywhere
maybe I don't worry about the rats it's
very it's very clean here uh-huh
did the rats clean up everything even
the other dead rats and dead cats that
we would see in taking the shortcut
very clean dead cats so you know he
emailed me after what he was like please
write a chip provides a review and I'm
like you know what I brought the dead
kid I'm just gonna email you some
constructive criticism about when my
family didn't feel safe but you know
just to help you out but I'm not gonna
do this publicly oh we're on a podcast
and he was gracious for the feedback but
the the food was the food was great
being in Bangkok was a great experience
and I just think that we soaked it in
and then we moved on to more resort life
which I'll get into in the next
installment well I think we can we can
wrap it up there I cover just a couple
other other details of things that
happen but it's it really kind of my
trip has definitely been overshadowed so
to speak by what happens yeah quit
licking your the enema please the what
happened to my mom which will
get into but before we go reckon effect
something that actually was very useful
on the the trip and something that gummy
fiber lock pointed out to me was this
website the true size comm which I know
it could that seems like it could be a
few different things but what it
actually is is it's a world map let me
show this to you the true size com
so it's a wet it's a website where you
type in a country so I've typed in
United Kingdom okay and then you can
take it you can move it all around the
world to see how big it is compared to
something you actually know so we we had
this argument like how big do you think
that UK is and I said I think it's
probably from Georgia to Virginia I said
that before and of course it that's
about how big it is but it also takes
into account this I can't remember the
name of there's an effect basically like
okay Greenland looks massive on a map
right like the global rap effect yeah
but there's a specific name for it I
think it's the global rap effect and so
let me put it in Greenland well I kind
of want to know how big Thailand is well
let me show you this so like okay here's
Greenland look to you looks massive but
when you bring it yes dang it's just
little man tiny so basically that effect
that is it's the whole idea of you've
got a stretching it if you try to take
the skin of a globe off it won't lay
down flat so basically as things move
towards the poles they get exagerating
lee large on a flat mat I think Thailand
will go from the bottom tip of Florida
up to Washington DC
okay so Thailand is kind of long it's
got this peninsula down there well I'll
put Thailand in there see Thailand th i
GH there it is
okay now drag that over to Florida it's
such a redneck thing to do how much
bigger is Thailand in Florida
oh my goodness way bigger what what
you're dragging it over the UK where are
you know the UK's already there cuz I'm
oh you
oh it stays you could create a no Pangea
you see that did you start at the tip of
Florida no put the tip of Thailand at
the tip aful ago and now did that go to
Washington DC it goes almost exactly
Washington DC okay well see because I've
traveled all over that land and of
course if you move it up here to the
polls I mean look how big it gets look
how big tiling is tiling is as big as
Greenland you're subverting me use this
thing okay you're rec has been in effect
man yeah the true size for those of you
who are very interested in the true size
of a country and how it coordinates to
where you're at or other places in the
world
hashtag ear biscuits let us know if you
want to contribute to the conversation
in any way or correct anything that we
said or things that we should have done
that we didn't do I'm sure you want to
do that oh you should have done this
it's like how are we gonna feel well you
know what am I gonna go back to Thailand
now so don't do that
and then next week we will find out what
happened a retz mob to watch more ear
biscuits click on the playlist on the
right to watch the previous episode of
your biscuits click on the playlist to
the left and don't forget to click on
the circular icon to subscribe if you
prefer to listen to this podcast it's
available on all your favorite podcast
platforms thanks for being your mythical
best
[Music]